I guess not all pixels cost the same
depend on the page I should really pay
attention to what effects I'm applying
and everything else I'm doing yep
exactly
although remember the cardinal rule
about performance mm thick measure first
then optimize exactly let's take a look
okay we're looking at a trace of the New
York Times home page we want to look at
paint events so let's filter out the
rest as you can see there are many paint
events but let me show you a handy trick
we can select the time range that we
want to show in a timeline by dragging
the sliders at the top here notice that
as we do this the pie chart on the
bottom is updated with the total times
yep
and also while we're here let's identify
some expensive paints for example this
one took 8 milliseconds hmm so let me
see we said that any time we want to
update the render tree there's a good
chance we'll have to run layout and I'm
guessing the same applies for painting
right that's right the browser applies a
lot of smarts and tries to repaint the
minimum required area but really it all
depends on what kind of updates are
being applied to the render tree